when i ride
it just feels like everything else
washes away
nothing is important other than what i'm
doing right there
that's just the best feeling ever that
feeling of freedom from everything
[Music]
my name is mark beaumont and i'm an
endurance athlete
with the current world record for
cycling around the planet
seeking adventures and finding stories
is what i'm most passionate about
ever since i can remember i've had that
sense of curiosity about the world
this time i've come to dubai
i'm going to meet dana a bike rider
who's been inspiring young girls all
over the uae
[Music]
i was born and raised in dubai so i've
lived here for 25 years i've been riding
dirt bikes since i'm 15.
growing up here my dad always taught me
how to do pretty much any sport that i
wanted to do i grew up learning how to
wakeboard to drive manual car things
like that i never felt like there was
anything i couldn't do just because i'm
a girl there's a sport that i want to
learn yeah let's go for it there's
nothing holding me back when i started
riding it just felt natural to do that
as well
i just loved it from the very beginning
so i started racing in the emirates
desert championship and that's a two
hour race around like a 20 to 25
kilometer loop and i was doing a couple
of those and then i started riding a bit
on the motocross track and they really
wanted more girls to be racing so i did
a couple of motocross races and then i
did one rally which was the dubai
international rally and that was
probably my favorite race ever
so let me show you the bikes that we're
gonna ride today this is uh pretty cool
yeah i'm not used to having an engine on
my bike
so these are the two bikes we're gonna
take out we've got the 450 sxf the 350
sxf i guess they're the same size of
bike it's just a bigger engine exactly
yeah and what's the idea we're going to
get out there and you're going to
show me the basics yeah so we'll maybe
just start on a flat area and i'll show
you as well like what kind of lines you
want to take in the dunes because you
don't really want to just go straight
over because that's quite rough on you
but yeah let's get you kitted up get the
bikes up and let's head into the desert
because it's such a melting pot of
cultures how would you reflect growing
up here yeah i mean having an
international culture around you is mine
is my normal it feels an odd not to have
that and yeah you get to learn so many
different cultures traditions how people
take how they work
[Music]
when i tell people about riding in the
desert i describe it kind of as like
surfing in the dunes it's like you're
cutting through butter cutting through
water it just feels so natural
it really does feel like you're just
painting a canvas and you find your
lines and when you find that good line
it just feels like poetry emotion like
you're surfing dunes it's just
perfect
the writing community here is just so
open and welcoming if it is because i'm
a girl that they're actually more
helpful there's so many different
nationalities you never feel like you
don't belong
is
how are you feeling it's a mixture
between sort of laughing in terror yeah
but you look a lot more comfortable than
just a few minutes ago yeah i mean it's
it's it's childlike isn't it it's just
that sheer glee yeah why did you keep
going i mean so many people will start
something and then when it's up to them
they they do something else but but you
you took it to the next level yeah i
kept going because i mean for me it was
something that really changed my life at
the time
i was in quite a dark place i wasn't
confident in myself it kind of made me
realize how awesome life actually can be
if the desert on the bike gave you
nothing else that that phrase it showed
me life could be awesome that would be
enough winter yeah no that's the best
gift i could have asked for i would love
to inspire the girls to ride if i can
give another girl that experience that i
had and that feeling of self-confidence
belonging that makes my day
at the heart of dana you go somebody
who's very very sweet and friendly and
simply want to show me the bite but a
fierce competitor like i can see that
undercurrent of i want to push this just
trying to keep up with her around the
dunes was was intimidating enough i mean
it was it was wonderful it was eye
opening it was it was scary but it was
it was seriously cool
[Music]